[Music]
our next guest is a comedian who can be
seen this sunday at the del close
marathon in new york city and whose
debut album dilation is available now
please welcome you're very funny rory
scoville
thank god how are y'all doing y'all
doing all right i'm
i'm nervous somebody honest i'm nervous
i don't usually do this kind of stuff
but i got i got some zizzle zazzles
let's get into it
i uh i was hanging out last week uh with
my meanwhile
and uh
we were watching that storage wars you
guys watch that
[Applause]
just what is it you know you watch
you're like this isn't a thing you watch
like they just people just bid on a
thing don't even know what's in it
what is that
i wish i could go in the night before
with a sharpie and right on some of the
boxes
so when they open up that unit door one
of the boxes just says really old
baseball cards
box underneath just says abraham lincoln
stuff like
david are you seeing that
i'm working on a new food series right
now to complement the lunchables
shut up let me finish it
it's called uh dinnerables
and breakfastables
so
oh you hear that right there that's the
sound everybody going oh i wish i
thought of that
y'all didn't you all didn't
i thought of it and i'm probably gonna
have a helicopter by the end of the year
you're like oh who are you going to
market it to who's going to buy it
how about parents who don't know how to
tell their kids are poor
that's not mean that's just shut up
you know that's not me i'm poor i can
say jokes like that
i'm reminded every time i go to watch a
movie that same
warning pops up on my screen this movie
has been formatted to fit this screen
it's like i get it i have a small tv
you're coming at me you're a vhs tape
my point is you had to have the kids
send them to school with a real lunch or
send them to school with a box inside a
bag like what do you got in that bag a
box
what's in the box just some ingredients
so i can kind of make some stuff
you know i got some crackers here just
like the worst kind of crackers not not
even saltines
i don't even want to tell you what i
would do for a captain's way for right
now but it's exactly what you just
thought of
then i got some turkey here some cheese
i guess that's cheese i don't know
my mom wanted me to just have some
crappy hors d'oeuvres for lunch
then lunchables tried to spice up like
oh we got many pizzas you want some
uncooked cold pizza we're like what yes
yes i do
[Music]
and then you open it up you're like no
this ain't it this ain't it at all this
isn't even close to what i thought it
would be
that's not marinara sauce that i can't
melt the cheese
i don't have access to a microwave
because i'm an elementary school student
okay
fix it lunchables
you're the one percent you're the
problem
y'all get it you know what i'm talking
about it starts tonight we put a new
occupy movement together we go down to
lunchables and we yell at the buildings
y'all are the worst kind of crackers
because that that's where they yell at
all the protests you know
[Applause]
a lot of our freedoms are getting taken
away in this country you guys know what
i'm talking about yeah can't yeah that
one woman
everyone else like no i think we're good
he's like i'm mad
can't text and drive anymore one of the
greatest freedoms we've ever experienced
remember that just got started you're
like oh man text and drive you're like
nah you can't you're like that [ __ ] that
just got started
i didn't even get a chance to see if i
was any good at
it the reality is most of us are good at
it
we're not idiots it's like two letters
eyes on the road
two letters eyes on the road
two letters eyes are here
you gotta have some patience
i'm not typing a paragraph i'm not an
author
i'll tell you one thing you are still
allowed to do though
a little freedom a lot of people don't
cash in on you are still allowed to
write a handwritten letter to a friend
and drive
everybody who claps loves freedom good
for you
cop pulls you over you just texting no i
wasn't okay
i was writing a handwritten letter in
calligraphy
[Applause]
to a friend of mine it's a chain letter
and if i don't write it they're gonna
kill my family
you're also allowed to uh you're allowed
to hide whenever you want to that's a
freedom a lot of people don't do then
some people like wherever no whenever
i know somebody you're like wait what if
nobody's looking for me do you really
need somebody looking for you
to muster up the adrenaline that comes
with hiding
i mean if you walked out of here right
now and you just saw a guy on the street
just like hiding
right away you're like what is this
what are you doing who's looking for you
nobody
nobody is
hey my name's rory scovel i appreciate
it guys thank you very much
hey
that's hilarious that was fantastic
[Applause]